your wish I signed them screw record
very much declarations of interest if
any disc i think i need to declare an
interesting I some specs for the
launcher sector glances around me thank
you very d and after anybody finds an
interest that I would sure that the
beginning please tell us then we'll make
sure it's recording rights 525 in masses
refer to the executive and reports from
other committees there are none so we go
straight to item 6 which is the progress
on the decision so like some sex and I'm
not proposing to go through encounter by
plane each I think its own templates
anyway a lot of this has now been
completed to be the great items on there
so that's really good does anybody wish
to pray that it gets busy thank you very
much excitingly through you to turn ugly
probably no 6.2 I think there's any kind
of interesting I was about to like that
from this please and as it is developed
over yet the campus and contagion and
update honesty and how fast the Queen to
safety have it is like it corrected the
estimated timeline now is April but I
think it's important that we note that
although the enzyme not together there
at the moment there is in good works and
downs with the specific data faction
that have been taking place
a community safety partnership with
their police inverness health care
planning officers and have been the
operation days from there's always one
each month but occasionally more than
modern ones in the homes and immigration
issues and there have been arrest made
between safety of several luxury
district it has we clean coveting
meeting for the glue that railway
station I'm going to go much in will
come back in this place could be
confirmed that some of the rumors are
circulating completely fallacious which
is going to be closed what's going to be
related education not that I'm aware of
I think they just spend a fair bit of
money in lifting up the settlers and
things in apparently this be yes I think
there's always rumors just learned of
some of its about that sort of thing
where they can work on it they
temporarily closing observing and again
I think it doesn't work there they've
done some great work that settings as
well every day recently there's no
immediate plans to claim your a lease
extension you know but who knows you
know it's not in our hands is it but
clearly at the moment you know it is a
symptom it's not absolutely what I think
we chose that they are quite where we
use unfortunately certainly fit not just
our history but for other areas as well
I can remember when we saw a spike in
crime and we might have on orkut earth
is going on because because they were
actually including all the figures that
they charged a trait a police station
but almost the whole south end area
because that's where they were taking
them but it wasn't actually a
programming tell the people strong so I
think you've got to be careful would you
look at some of these figures but the
bokonim I'm not wear throughout through
other channels that
you know that so he is just a rumor but
I understand the Aeons have one should
have now got a sold sign outside so I
bridging the offices of the for
PlayStation of orchard is now himself so
we can to be mysterious know that I
don't vote this embryo starts now
presumably it's for development on the
sugar mr. development whether they will
develop it as is or changing or can be
then remove any nuts so you want some
paint tool yeah Italy's PA 06 point
forward Lisa you landed 30 to London
Road having a meeting with not how it
applies learn Tesco's are dragging their
feet with regard as one please land but
looking at some recent photos is helping
safety issue there so I've come to a
decision to which I'll be probably
emailing that that will put some of the
bowlers around that stripped land and we
saw it so it's work between your way
Marcus emit fo that we are hopefully
that will speed up the process for them
to and negotiator the least bit quicker
okay but it no see a shin visually it's
not through the local that location 0 is
sweet than other parties it is and of
course obscenely that's quite a larger
obviously life and realize I cities so
you know things those are careful with
that yeah Emily I was getting on can you
can't buy that George you're putting
followers round it just making it solid
and a magnet comes back to Marcus of
them are the hope that we cannot Marcus
will you get that electrode company to
we do the land because it's all churned
up and that's what mammal saying that we
use electro completo put the Duvall odds
of the wooden bowl odds he has no
maintenance
your next section is gross correct right
that's what wrestling also impurity I do
it and lovely the sectional and
bluegrass will be people down here at
nighttime ok English things I was just
going to say that I think query metal
because we have several medicines
complaining about the Asian Thursday
linking twitter's let's examine tiny
sliver insolvency that hard ride instead
which it hadn't been that was working on
completing your valve suitable ok we
talking about the soda bottles the gun
down or just put out a lot of government
I think that was the problem I think
with the existing ones because anybody
could just leave these are going to
become a wooden bowl of a mr. Vieira how
the bad news i reserve the growth it was
an end of the environmental friendly but
it also means that segment that will be
complaint Tedesco because people can't
park yes exactly like you or the
dragoness ate another some sorry I'm six
military ball 3 volt research around the
come after a while well Selena however
it was small sum of money that fella and
with the living room did word out of the
system which we would look at that
remaining pop media to see whether it
was required based on knowledge that
squadron de Gothia from the operations
of various volunteer organizations and
in district and keep you yeah just going
back to the test posting as a piece of
ground you're talking about as you look
at Tescos ins to the right of the LA
spew there is just the left of the
essence because I where there's a small
triangle piece which is in our ownership
again that could people could climb
across that beginning all of us also
includes its own artist question yeah
that's that's also be included in
rotation which we thought okay okay but
not successfully she'll be fine although
my 32 chair please I very literary
critic authority for took a different
asks I mean everybody list of
organizations who were awarded the grant
Island Web member yes you know the area
to all members skin normally does the
pistol clogging up it's quite a lot of
information they're starting they're
still playing too much don't you tell
you the fans don't reply yet so you are
providing the reports all right okay
thank you very much anybody else on any
of the other places please yeah just to
say that the reason the air quality
management plan and grant ready as yet
is it's being put forward to key
decisions footfall to march in in order
to take into account honestly responses
in the confrontation and get the costing
and perfectly before then can then come
up with revised plan so that we move
forward month oh come on thank you much
it's interesting that I think I've seen
the traffic increase I believe because
of the work they're doing okay gnomes
from the moment I think a lot of people
are driving round rather than going down
the ones who said the music up so
anything's really at the moment yes you
can take a view on it but they might be
skewed by such work yes of course when
it's done integrating but before then
nothing you know you've got a that's
look at that and taking context or
perhaps do another one afterwards I
don't know but I think you look at how
that's coming forward and any data from
this year and I think Shawn will correct
me if I'm wrong won't be verified until
next July
it's a free month of the year end
collection for desa and holder
adjustment that's right to ask me if you
delete your telling any event but I'm
you quite well welding chair and they're
always risks around this in terms of
rude works and so on and we've seen that
happen on a number of occasions when
they did previous ruling in networks and
guests as well and they're happy
diluting yeah the date for the term and
now to be found a little better not okay
once i'm going to pull to that in
thinking any of this please so members
you know the reports about so I'm 37
then this is the faulty report from the
section one by one or so and we very
work for than that what's really going
to golden fasting is it a little bit the
bank teacher home I don't propose to go
through the report in detail SS
questions but I will just highlight some
key points first page seven point two
paragraph 3 plus 2 there is a table in
there just on a highlight one figure
four hundred and twenty six thousand
four hundred twenty seven thousand pound
that is our forecast underspend and at
the end of this financial year so 31st
to march end of this month that is where
we are forecasting to be against college
budget which is obviously a a healthy
position underneath the key savings and
expenditure items rather through some of
those so Marcus is done kajabi
negotiates in some of his contracts
driving costs down so ninety four
thousand pounds over there in the year
and
the car park display hi display revenue
is up mainly through volume and are we
had only the increase in ticket prices
earlier in the year but its volume is
gone second season tickets as well which
is good very controlling companies to
say is showing positive at the moment
and has continued to do so through to
the end of the year we've got a few
savings around office combination
repairs and maintenance costs nature of
where we're at with office accommodation
at the moment and where we might be in a
few years time pending whatever is going
to happen some of the works have been
reduced just keeping us to lack of these
to be damaging clearly from health and
safety point of view so as the saving
their against those non essential
repairs and maintenance on the flipside
we also still have some concerns around
office around tech accommodation and
this report just highlights what members
are already aware of and what they have
been made aware of through the budget
process this year which is expenditure
looking like about 200,000 vampire on DB
accommodation pre-application planning
advice isn't doing as well as it was
expected 25,000 power under income there
and local and charging cream as well as
looking to be referenced sales and
whether there are main variances to
budget both positive and a negative way
but as I say it's looking healthy
overall i would just like to point out
one error on page 7.14 to bring your
attention a simple gun for and
homelessness there they shouldn't be
brackets around that and sent to tell
you not very moment that i dress very
sad but the thing is still type it's
just the back it should be have exactly
Christmas Genesis ask them as far as
their for physics there's mr. so that
just go swing the balance in favor of
yes so and that will be transferred into
general fund reserve at the endless
frontier by the ones we wonder final
accounts through my journey lighting
will though yet so I know it could
change but that's the full cast at the
moment and then they'll be a decision
from general fund balance where that and
then go into my transformations are all
right just one more thing about when you
spoke about maintenance I mean yes of
course health and safety you must get
all the safety but the only other thing
you know that it's a judgment call is
that what you don't want is if you get a
hole in a roof and it's going to cost
you ten times as much if you leave it
yeah so from that point of view it's
about being a fair value we feel like
making sure if you do need a repair then
is that Rick area or you know attention
to something that you make sure that
that's brought forward you know rather
than just put to one side because
obviously it can be very much worse if
you just leave it I think that's
something you you always we doing with
our own budgets you know
the council property etc going forward
you know I'm not sure that's done
already but that's the only cool to not
answer that so some just health and
safety it's about essential maintenance
sometimes it's a fun story if you wanted
to be critical you could look at this
budget and say that this year we got our
budget miles wrong because there's such
a big saving but the reality is nothing
to be further than the truth that finger
the potential underspend as a result of
people working harder people being more
efficient good contracts being
negotiated a proper awareness of what's
coming into the future and an
increasingly difficult Financial Times
it could be said that the the car
parking is the results of good economic
strategy young so than the work with
fathers in town council encouraging gun
incurring directing marine ready to
cover an even more thriving local center
so I'm really pleased with with that
budget and i think that the work that
has been done so far this year is
setting it up for being able to set
future budgets which are more in line
with the decreased level of income
that's going to be coming our way and
it's a piece of work where we've got and
got in early would recognize what the
wonderful passes from the economic
environment I'm started to work towards
it too because you said before their
turn to Katie applause so soon yeah I
mean nothing big bit coming not for a
while is everything that we going into
negative rate support rods and we don't
know yet what's going to happen with the
business rates which will be coming soon
reviews and come into the future and
what price tag that cup of what what
streams that comes with as far as
bring the ride so until we know that I
think you've got we have to be prudent
in any of it and obviously this is a
good contribution to that and then
something we take forward but every year
you've got to try and cut the essay cut
your cloth but there's only a set of a
certain amount plus that you can clap
how many do that you provide services
how many savings go into the the phone
campers from the future and take some
initiatives indeed in okay it's easy
it's just a couple of observations place
you live in the car park since I
invention you know how to help raylene
astronics yes and it's really made a
huge contribution then you can see that
through council road where r Adams gone
are immensely basically two marks and
spencers being then think wiring that
you actually fall to the table beta was
business might step and and he'll that
will affect Riley and how that will
impact on the smaller independent
businesses within violate that are one
of the drawers that actually help to
fill the car box so you know I think
we're going to have to be very much
aware of what's going on especially what
the Chancellor is planning to do in
result from statement you know I think
it's going to be quantities ultimate
angular 1 there's another one came
together its offices it's popping yeah
another market belong together so he's
looking to actually find ways that you
can help to soften the body which means
being flagged up by everybody that could
be a bit worried whistle which I think
they took me in a moment of our personal
savings and contributions and help those
SI units it's the unknown isn't it
nobody really knows where they're going
to be only been indications but not
nothing over there so you type of
questions if I Mike pick it up on a
favor car parks you make some season
tickets are up is that a particular car
park is there a particular reason
because of going back two or three years
ago it was
depressed I wonder what sudden changes
to improve and I have to get back to
your detail Avery's mainly Iranian web
supply with really interesting laughter
oh I have talent that just plated yes
the right and I bet has only God
significant sure nothing is every
likelihood it collects the comments that
the discerning lead evokes of smarts
fancy and I think generally the the
positive business environment that we
have in that in really at the moment and
these are the more businesses there are
lightly of it is that there's more of a
demand for season tickets Alice positive
it was the approach example was so what
you never looked on critters that the
PCT and well-known psychic what will you
use council right moment for memory
rather get shot i'll be asleep i think i
think we get the figures from time
planning and we do not bring them down
the other question what guys was
currently i work with the domestic rates
of leaflets it's been split between
county ourselves parishes police and
fire is it likely that have a syllabus
for with a business point will resolve
all the parishes we benefits a lot of
the new business rates from 2020 onyx
some known as a moment don't wanna know
you believe it relevé presented the
magazines i love on the split of
visitors every night I can't see how
they couldn't speak it continuously on
some households and preceptors but with
detail young which automatically be
interesting I'm the work a lot of work
taking place around business reason I
think of trial pilon due to start
immediately but I mean I think for me
the keys not necessarily that the fear
of the work on the fair funding formula
because
I think that the the key to we will see
our finances in the future as my
understanding that the fair funding
formula where decision is on that will
come into operation indeed before that
the new business rate mechanism you know
in other words we'll we'll find out how
much we get keep and you know I have a
sneaking suspicion the news will not be
wolves will not be able will be
fantastical doubt whether it'll be in
our favor that's very that way yeah and
putting the other news is I mean they
look in a government departments now
opportune that's an interesting with
interesting words that used by
advertised up to six percent I think
that you know if we the sixth played for
us we'd be very pleased with me but
there you are but let's see how that
goes as well but I know in certain
counties saving money for some of the
things we have in our services are
sponsored by county and other they're
looking very closely at their not just
this year but in future years and of
course they've got the added burden and
there's the social side and social
delivery so you know it's not going to
be easy over the next few years so the
best that we can get to now is going to
be that but i think i am you know
without business engagement now that
we're doing through that carries and
other things no I'm pleased that that
might come into the frame as well but
there I say we save some money on
appointing Sean as as our telling ok
service you know these are the sort of
initiatives I think we've got to look to
in the future and sometimes you've got
to make difficult decisions about what
your priorities going forward and those
priorities are going to reflect that
hopefully what people are there are
thinking as well and still provide the
services that they're expecting of us
and homelessness is obviously one of
those so you know hopefully we did some
of the development is going for what
they will see some of that
as well we have got some other irons in
the fire too so you know I think we've
got the business development going
through the business park as well so I
think you know that we've got that
future to look forward to and there are
there are plans and there are good
things coming forward for Rogers and we
are a real player in that as far as
south essex is concerned and we will be
able to we're working well with our
colleagues in south in throughout South
it excludes as good conversations going
on it's now what they call it one sort
of opportunity south essex now is that
attends gateway which i think speaks for
itself and i think the new lady that's
in charge of that glory Iran is doing a
sterling work I think we're going to
really get him getting in our stride as
for us and that's concern and we're part
of that too so I think there are some
good things coming forward but we've
still got to be careful and prudent
about what our care we go forward so do
you want to say something onto one turn
my soliloquy another contract and a
couple of things that the main thing is
just just a comment about homelessness
in them this is a method on this paste
them on fire to the number of chemicals
emergency accommodation census form I
think it's also about inertia in January
for a hundred research approaches to
healthy community I'm surprised that
I've been averaging about 1,900 so we
beginning to serious escalation and I
know that we were self but I'm sure I
remember you had direct approaches and
relatives in quite dire situations that
thing working hard by chemical you
members not appointed and being trained
when I just working flat out and read
for what they're dealing with their go
really going to move on Pilates is doing
sturdy children that keeps getting
answers
joey del inca they prepare yourself
desperate for wanting to find homes for
people that are tiny and the other fun
with justice and on page amazon for and
against public health money along even
onto some ways that no it's it's within
my budget area to someone that dynamite
I think it's also sit for decision is
nothing like you know [ __ ] they'll open
spaces these things like it's lonely
drainage of the planet that seem to be
exactly the amount or maybe no its
twenty six thousand from Jesus Navas
Tara and I confused chances will zoom
did we leave any kind of like that
either public it's a fire it's got some
memories got the side of the contract
element and I can I can train dogs and I
think we'll get a clarification yeah for
the strange name but it but the budget
have in there that's only unfortunately
for me to deliver it to stuff like a
stray dog saloon I need to talk to you
sometimes I can confirm the public
health improve posture doesn't sound
right now thank you for coming to be
able to show you the spending less
painful as a pilgrim from shifting Ellen
social in and out of it so you can go
and could have taken that hapless
although I just put some caramelization
okay and I made that in January they
have the situation I believe in severing
the team of the situation remembers
being we're all
we mostly and outside the district were
full and extend another own child to be
intense nuttin paid accommodation no
idea i am only optionality could at
least I had that accommodation that's
the thing that a refund a bit difficult
and I've just going to say we had quite
a discussion around us the other day
with nick from the lack of point of view
looking at those sort of issues and if
some of that information to come forward
and is quite worried in all of them know
each other solutions right okay thank
you the Gimli ones for Francis cartilage
is available for that will help relieve
your situation yes well 17 units Germany
with it will make substantial
differences members know that there was
a reference to that in the in the budget
gal you to come two weeks ago 22 cents
days it's not you to come in cuse
straight away and hope I don't drop I
think this work being done is there also
to make sure we covered ocean is
contraband all 10 current tenants have
now been offered and accepted
alternative content it should have to
have to be very careful about that
because you're dealing with vulnerable
people so it's quite right that you know
take our time with them to make sure
they're happy thoughts come from but
yeah okay all right any other questions
please thanks my man right I'll take the
petition in its entirety 1.12 one point
for our members are bringing that we
were you thank you much all right so our
tonight is the border between automatic
restaurant I think a very nice picture
in papers they know what's coming on
that at all don't take sure that they
didn't I do have good
attunity I think it's a pity since my
even angry bow because we initially look
for firefighting I think we've
progressed on as a as a section to
become more probable now example
actually being a position to be more
constructive and this is just one of the
scenarios that we've been involved in
there are others down the road that we
are working on Mar Vista cell phone and
wood routines and other people within it
this is just the first of what we are
will be a succession of good use doors
not be as much much more about German
the table setting office has got any
further commentary he wants to try but
because we got the right for the people
at the moment who are all looking
forward they all see what we're trying
to achieve and they want to be part of
it so I don't think we can argue against
them accepting a problem the only
decision we have to make these about the
4500 but I think within the decision
that should say about the 4500 and that
was pointed out to me in another place
because we got on there to approve grant
award for we like the outside but I
think we need to prove the allocation
and fauna of thousand don't worry too so
that we can accept the grant 45 found
nothing we need to make the decision to
say that produces degree yes yeah I
think that's where we are with is that
right it will be clear this before half
pound and pound is used to an existing
budgets yeah bro say it ain't pretty so
thank you approve 25,000 pounds a week
to spend on and play equipment so my
view was a full health value nor
decision that I was gifted to make
we no harm in the resolution I think it
clarify you verified in addition there
for our thousand of an existing budget
shall we say will be utilized towards
the grant award organica 45 pounds
comprehensive or perhaps words in that
is done just to make it clear example
you look to that thank you for coming
full I sales of twenty- we're not a
program 2.5 term proposed comes provide
necessary contribution to 4.5 yeah cool
down from five spaces can use weapons
which are getting cool program in the
decision I think that was ever made
dealer I think we try and decide so I
members happy to that yes let me take
that forward thank you well I too may
also you're gonna clean yeah so I 29 is
a timetable of meetings you've got the
timetable their members if anybody
wishes to speak on any of the items on
that one thank you that's on that side
beginning yeah I think it was just too
much away guys the first British Way day
has been quite well attended but the the
second one was was less while attentive
and most of business was done in the
morning so for officer possibly members
convenience as well suggest that the
second purchase away day was done as an
evening session and concise and then
this potentially small cost-saving there
as well yeah and I think if we started
at seven involvement 730 I think that
would be acceptable other one you know
Charlie recently and of course there
will be somebody savings within you know
not running out etc so and I think so I
all members can get to this week in and
take emotional you know I appreciate you
know it does when you when you have a
radio show up in the mine but when we're
in position where we're really just
presenting where we are we know after
all the discussions that have gone on I
think we know it's a good thing to do so
thank you for that
there is no deity who were possible
arrived talented in a room away from the
council chamber because of the council
chamber is where we can't argue with
each other to the point that we wait a
second though depending on numbers of
course this room could be utilized
budgetary am really I think you can get
building members in here anything it's a
theater style presentation you have time
to come yeah yeah yeahs won't worry when
we can't even look at what the old town
you know sorry anyone's your pollution
to continue it on the satellite or
challenging to the Midway on omegle it
fine ok and I think that would be much
better I same in October one's there to
say I think we can other than that are
there any preferences relating to the
timetable so members except that the
applicants were you angry thank you
right we come down to the time it was
the owners private and confidential
we're off right so